all we going to do is we're going to
look at this and we are going to take
this idea or Hillary angle and say if I
take two trig functions like this and
combine them should be able to write
them as one trig function with a
different amplitude of different faves
okay and I'm going to use the auxiliary
angle to find that thing what am I going
to do I'm going to compare I'm going to
say I know that this will happen in some
way I just don't know what the amplitude
or the phase are okay so therefore I'm
going to say let this thing here this
root 3 or 2 sine X plus 3 on to college
X I know it should end up as a single
trig function so I'm just going to give
that trig function and name I don't know
what ever she is by convention we use
the capital winner are sine and then I
know the phase will also change but I
don't know how much buying so I also do
that name alpha is the most common
letter you'll see in their feet is also
fine whatever you like me okay now I'm
predicting that this will happen and I
need to know what these pieces are so
just like we do here I'm going to use my
expansion my trig expansion for this and
see what happens
so watch with me if I expand this out
I've got an R right out the front and
then I'm going to have this big long
expansion in the middle right what am I
going to have sine X cos alpha plus
convex side up okay well by the way I
miss timing remember I've said I'm
introducing this funny function I don't
know what the amplitude will be I don't
know what the phase will be but I'm
going to find them what that says is
these are actually numbers they're not
variables like X are actually equal to
something I'm going to find out what it
is alphas also equal something on final
use so you need to stay that R and alpha
are numbers I go usually fine I look
like so variables that can change
idiot okay I've got my extension now
let's see where this takes us I'm going
to reframe this ever so slightly you
probably won't notice much of a
difference cut in a minute you'll see
why I'm reframing it this way I'm going
to write our cos alpha Q and then I'm
going to write our sine alpha here all
I've done so as a constant all I've done
is I've expanded like multiplied
everything to by our and I've also
slightly rearranged these terms
okay here's why I've done that remember
when we started root 3 1 2 sine X plus 3
on pseudo convex okay
look carefully now that we have on the
left and on the right we saw a situation
like this back when we were working with
quadratic functions sometimes if you've
got something on the left and something
on the right and you're saying they're
equal and you've got the same kinds of
things on both sides which is visit by
doing with there as well you can compare
them look at the sine X on the Left how
many of them do you have you have root 3
on two of them right so that's your
point 86 something okay but on the right
side also silences how many do I have
I have our quad alpha of them whatever
that happens to equal to right I'm
matching up the sine X on the left and
the sine X's on the right I can do
exactly the same thing for the person
straight look this is how many of them I
have on the left and this is how many I
have of them on the right those numbers
to be the same so therefore I can say by
comparison
our cause alpha equals this and our sine
alpha equals that okay you see what I've
done I look at the coefficients on each
side and I've said match signs and sines
cosines and cosines two coefficients out
the front or to be the same okay
yeah I've set out to write this down and
I want to know what for new amplitude
what is the phase shift look at your
Guillory angle is okay you've got two
unknowns are alpha you've got two
simultaneous equations right to your
nodes two equations I can solve this I
can use this all the information I need
to find out what each value is how shall
we do it though you usually get your
accountants present you used to see
something like this something like that
right you see these before you know
exactly what to do what would you do in
this case this one I've set up so it's
nice and easy to eliminate there's a 2x
and 2x you would just subtract one
equation from the other the X's are
going to gone you'll have something to
do with these and then you could solve
for y right you know that if you've got
two equations in two variables you've
got to somehow turn them into one
equation in one variable right so
somehow you got to do something with
these guys to put them together to
either get rid of the ass or get rid of
the alphas how do we do it would anyone
like to suggest something weak
you can divide an equation to vacation
planning it lady okay now just pause for
a second I keep the most obvious thing
to do is say if I've got not here not
here if I divide one by the other than
art will cancel and and so it says if
you do this divider like this you just
have turn out four equals some number
and it ought to go okay now that's not a
really bad idea it's quite clever
because it gets rid of your eyes you
want to assume it does however have a
problem that I'm going to highlight for
you in a minute so rather than do that I
just want you to sort of store down the
back in mind we'll come back to that a
second even though it's less obvious
getting rid of ours is not as good as
getting rid of your outfit now I'm going
to ask if what I wanted to do was get
rid of office what could I do
you know we I gave you triggered any
proofs sometimes and sometimes an
identity looks really nice and simple on
both sides and you had to make it
Messier
before it would get meetup right one of
those common things you would do is if
you've got squares you can work with
squares like 1 squared + 5 squared they
work together they play nicely right so
sometimes you have to multiply by
something in order to make that happen I
don't have squared so if I want to
introduce them or I can take and have an
equation the whole thing and I can
square it what would that give you R
squared is holy queen it would be you
don't do everything right R squared cos
squared alpha and then over here to be
three quarters would be okay I can
square that I can also square this
equation right if I square not soon I'll
get R squared sine squared alpha equals
right on for right now if I have a
square cos square alpha and a squared
signs without line now I can get rid of
the alphas how do I do it
the COS present I squared is 1 right
provided you add them let's do it on the
left hand side I'm gonna have this Plus
this
you see I've squared them and I have
added them and for two things I've done
of you on the right hand side I'm going
to Square and add those as well
three points nine quarters
how's your brain going see what I've
done and do you see what I have done it
I'm going to factor it out that
r-squared now subscribe to my trade with
twelve divided by four is but this is
really really R squared times this this
is just one so R squared is three and
four bikini guy gave our trick and I
just said let's just go for positive
values of R you can actually do negative
values that is no reason it just
unnecessarily complicate things so
therefore there is one and only one
solution to this namely what does I
represent against before I tricky
question and answer in the air patoot I
found the amplitude for this new
function okay